vin diesel is one of the biggest stars
in hollywood
from fast and furious to xxx and
guardians of the galaxy here are the
films that made big bucks for vin diesel
if you're a big tough action movie star
in hollywood you're going to end up in
at least one cutesy kids movie
for vin diesel his chance to engage with
this sacred tradition came with the
pacifier
a 2005 kids movie from disney the
pacifier has now largely been forgotten
by general pop culture but at the time
of its release it was a juggernaut money
maker for the mouse house
opening in march 2005 the pacifier
proved to be one of diesel's bigger
projects as he tried to make a name for
himself beyond dominic toretto xander
cage and riddick
released right around spring break the
film proved to be a go-to option for
families looking to get out of the house
and watch diesel try to wrangle a group
of mischievous
kids filling that sort of need in the
marketplace helped the pacifier
eventually score a lifetime 198 million
dollar worldwide gross
which was more than three times its 56
million dollar budget
though this film provided diesel's first
time operating in the world of family
comedies the reliable formula of action
stars flabbergasted by precocious
youngsters had struck gold again
the fast and the furious was not meant
to be a blockbuster it was a classic
case of counter programming
a smaller crime thriller carrying a
budget of 38 million dollars and no
movie stars meant to play opposite big
summer 2001 heavyweights like angelina
jolie's first tomb raider movie but then
a funny thing happened on the way to the
movie theater
audiences turned out for the fast and
the furious in droves
ask any racer any real racer it don't
matter if you win by an
inch or a mile that's right winning's
winning
shattering all expectations furious
revved up its engine to the eventual
tune of 206.4 million dollars worldwide
in a summer populated by big budget
projects starring predominantly white
league characters the fast and the
furious and its diverse cast of street
racers allowed moviegoers of color the
rare chance to see people like
themselves on the big screen and a piece
of escapist entertainment
in the end this modest minded action
flick that got its title from a
forgotten 50's roger corman film would
end up spawning a cottage industry of
spin-offs rip-offs and sequels that
continue to this day
back in the early 2000s extreme sports
were edgy and cool and so was vin diesel
on paper putting them together was a
foolproof way to make some easy cash at
the box office
as it turned out financial reality
exceeded expectations
triple x hit theaters just a year after
the fast and the furious had turned
diesel into a box office
force reimagining him as james bond for
the x games generation
grossing 267.2 million dollars worldwide
triple x owed a lot of its success to
being diesel's first star vehicle right
after furious had taken pop culture by
storm
marketing that emphasized the spectacle
of diesel engaging in all kinds of
ridiculous extreme sports stunts also
proved effective in luring in movie
goers
the box office gross of diesel's extreme
adventure helped give birth to a new
franchise diesel famously abandoned for
its second installment
only to return triumphantly for its
third early 2000s culture got smashed
into one movie with
xxx and the resulting box office was as
extreme as any gnarly skateboarding
trick
after 15 years extreme diesel was back
with 2017's return of xander cage
sure he had technically died off screen
in triple x state of the union but would
death really stop an actor like ben
diesel
in many ways diesel's homecoming didn't
mean much to domestic audiences
the film opened to just 20 million
dollars stateside above the debuts of
fellow post 2010 diesel vehicles like
riddick and the last witch hunter but
not great for a movie that cost 85
million dollars to make
where the return of xander cage truly
thrived was overseas where the film
ended up making 301.4 million dollars
thanks to those lucrative international
territories xander cage had managed to
produce another profitable adventure as
well as the biggest entry worldwide in
the
xxx franchise so far it had taken quite
some time for the character to return
but diesel proved here that there was
still plenty of appeal in the xander
cage character
after two sequels that both failed to
get vin diesel and paul walker back
together not to mention tokyo drift
hitting a lower box office hall than the
preceding films it looked like the fast
and the furious series was headed for
the direct-to-dvd
bin however 2009's fast imperius managed
to reunite all of the stars of the
original movie for the first time since
it began
and it paid off the feature smashed onto
the box office scene with a 70.5 million
domestic opening weekend significantly
ahead of expectations and at that point
in time by far the biggest debut for a
movie opening in april
in the span of one weekend the fast and
the furious franchise had gone from
being on life support to recharged and
ready to roll
by the time a theatrical run was
finished fast and furious had managed an
impressive 359.3 million dollar
worldwide gross
believe it or not there was once a time
when a movie featuring vin diesel did
not plaster the man's name all over its
marketing materials
such was the case with saving private
ryan a steven spielberg hit that
introduced diesel to much of the world
in the sixth build role of private first
class adrian caparzo
saving private ryan wasn't just a hit by
the standards of grim dramas released in
the summer
it was a smash by any metric a box
office success
grossing 485 million dollars ryan became
that rare massive hit equally appealing
to general moviegoers and award season
voters alike
it also proved to be the last r-rated
movie to top the yearly domestic box
office until american sniper arrived in
2014
diesel's role was relatively small and
not an integral part of the film's
success
but it was the first time the then
unknown actor was associated with a
studio film
and it was quite an introduction to
mainstream audiences
to get to the fifth installment in a
series you must be doing something right
at the box office
still prior to fast five the fast and
furious movies hadn't been as big as
say star wars or spider-man films
worldwide
past five was the injection of super
powered box office that this franchise
had been looking for
the feature grossed an enormous 630.1
million dollars worldwide
a 75 increase over the worldwide gross
of fast and furious
it also redefined the kind of box office
success that movies released in april
could be expected to deliver
how did fast five managed to revitalize
a franchise an entire decade into its
existence
the solution turned out to be upgrading
certain parts of the fast and furious
vehicle
bringing all the action to brazil rather
than the american settings of many of
the previous films also helped to expand
its overseas appeal
as did shifting to larger scale stunt
work and a heist movie tone
and also didn't hurt to have dwayne
johnson around the fast and the furious
will forever be vin diesel's signature
franchise and with fast five the
franchise hit a new high at the
worldwide box office
with guardians of the galaxy vin diesel
finally stepped into a marvel comics
adaptation
however unlike the majority of his film
roles diesel would not be visible on
screen in guardians
instead he would be providing voice work
for the titular team's resident tree
alien groot who only says the words
i'm rude much like the iron giant
diesel's deep baritone proved perfect
for the character
man groot would offer diesel the chance
to debut the character in one of the
most lucrative movies of his career
hitting movie theaters at the start of
august 2014 guardians of the galaxy
annihilated all expectations with a
gargantuan 333.7 million
domestic gross and a worldwide sum of
770 770.8 million dollars
these unknown galactic superheroes
turned into household names overnight
and the voice work of diesel was a key
reason why groot has become so beloved
by the general public
much as he did with his fast and furious
movies diesel saw the value of appearing
in a larger ensemble cast rather than
just embracing a one-man show just for
himself
by appearing alongside various other
cosmic marvel weirdos diesel secured one
of his highest grossing movies ever
with fast and furious 6 the furious
franchise wasn't just going to
london it was also returning to the
summertime a domain where the first
three entries premiered
after years of spring openings the
franchise would be taking on blockbuster
titans
and a question lingered would it be able
to continue its box office momentum
turns out there was no need to be
concerned even while opening in a month
that included iron man 3 and star trek
into darkness
fast and furious 6 proved a massive
force to be reckoned with at the box
office
grossing 789.3 million dollars worldwide
the flick more than doubled the
worldwide gross of fast and furious from
just four years prior
rather than harming the series fast and
furious 6 thrived into a summertime home
as a result vin diesel's box office
notoriety also flourished with this
movie becoming his first feature to ever
crack
700 million dollars worldwide in the
summer of 2014 the guardians of the
galaxy entered the box office as
unknowns
a bunch of d-list comic book characters
whose ability to pull in moviegoers was
in question
one smash sleeper hit later guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 entered the summer
of 2017 marketplace as a returning hero
now everyone knew who star-lord and
groot were and d-list comic book
fixtures had become a-list movie stars
grossing 869.1 million dollars worldwide
volume 2 improved on its predecessor's
worldwide box office gross and cemented
that these characters were no one movie
flukes even with a new version of groot
on the team
the adorable baby groot still voiced by
diesel was everywhere on toys posters
and tv spots for guardians of the galaxy
vol 2
capturing the hearts of moviegoers
before the movie even opened diesel's
baby groot helped to promise moviegoers
that they wouldn't just be getting the
first guardians again with this new
sequel
it's no wonder then that guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 scored so much success
at the box office that it became
diesel's biggest non-fast and furious
movie of all time
with the 2017 entry the fate of the
furious a furious movie made less than
its predecessor for the first time since
tokyo drift in 2006.
although not an ideal turn of events it
was inevitable given that this film was
following up on furious 7 which had
taken the franchise to new
astronomical box office heights it was
unreasonable to expect vin diesel's
signature franchise to keep topping
itself worldwide but fate still managed
to do just fine on its own merits
grossing 1.2 billion dollars worldwide
the fate of the furious was the second
biggest entry in the franchise by a
massive margin
though diesel's furious movies were no
longer consistently one-upping each
other in terms of box office halls
fate showed that this series could still
easily shift things into high gear and
deliver impressive box office numbers
though it was the seventh entry in the
furious saga furious 7 was far from a
routine movie in the franchise
for one thing this was the first entry
in the series since too fast too furious
to not be directed by justin lin with
james juan instead sitting in the
director's chair
even more notably though this would be
the last furious title to feature paul
walker's brian o'connor
after walker's tragic death in a car
accident in november 2013 the film was
reworked to become a tribute to his
memory
the headlines of this being walker's
final movie lingered over the film's
release
and furious 7 showed fans were eager to
see him one last time
the film far exceeded the normal box
office for a furious movie in numerous
countries around the world
and when the dust had settled the film
had more than doubled the worldwide
gross of fast and furious 6 to score
1.563 billion dollars worldwide
vin diesel's highest worldwide grossing
movie ever went far beyond anyone's
expectations
allowing the leading man to pay tribute
one last time to a friend and co-star
who had helped define his
exceptional career it's never goodbye
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one